مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره يتنفع
[موسيقى]
كان على قوله اخواننا المصريين لانه كان
فعلا يوم مانشستر سيتي بامتياز خلينا نبدا
مع مانشستر سيتي واحكي عن 3 نقاط رئيسيه
اول نقطه رح احكي عنها هي جوارديولا نفسه
غوارديولا اللي تعلم من اخطاء الماضي
غوارديولا اللي شفناه انسان برغماتي اكثر
صار اللي شفناه قادر ينوع ويغير بافكاره
بالشكل المطلوب مع الحفاظ على قوام الفريق
الرئيسيه وعلى قدرته على انه يبني لعب
وياسس للعب بالشكل الصحيح ويشكل خطوره على
مرمى الخصوم بشكل قوي جدا وبنفس الوقت
يحافظ على صلابته وتوازنه الدفاعي على
مدار سنوات الكل كان بيعرف انه جوارديولا
مشكلته الرئيسيه مع كل الفرق اللي دربها
كان الدفاع الموسم هذا جوارديولا دفاعه
نار نحن عم نحكي عنه تلقى تقريبا خمسه
اهداف على مدار البطوله حاليا بدوري
الابطال وهو رقم ممتاز جدا بالنسبه لفريق
طيب كيف جوارديولا قدر يوصل لهذه المعادله
كيف قدر انه يحسن دفاعه ويخلي المانشستر
سيتي يبدو وكانه فريق ايطالي بالدفاع لا
يقهر ابدا الاعتماد على خطه الثلاثه سته
واحد سميها ما شئت انا هيك بحب سميها ولكن
هي الخطه الجوارديولا وجد فيها ضالته بكل
المقاييس الاعتماد على جون ستون جون ستونز
كان معروف قبل انه هو لاعب يعني مدافع
اوكي باحسن احواله هو بيؤدي اداه دفاعيه
جيده وبيقدم شويه مسانده هجوميه لما يكون
مطلوب منه بالركنيات وما الى ذلك ولكن هذا
الموسم ستونز اكتشفناه بمركز جديد وهو نص
الملعب لا بل انه بهدف السيتي الاول على
ريال مدريد حزير وين كان جونس كان ظهير
ايمن جون ستونز كان ظهير ايمن كان حرفيا
تمركز لعيبه السيتي كظهير ايمن ووكل راجع
لورا شوي على نفس خطوه كان موجود
سيلفا داخل بالهاف سبيس او بنصف المساحه
يعني على شكل مربع هذا الامر خلى كروس
وفينيسيوس يروحوا يغطوا على بشكل غريب جدا
وكانه ستونز هو يعني
ولا ولا برناردو سيلفا بنفس الوقت كان
كمافينجا طالع يغطي على ووكر مشان ما يعطي
باص
بالمقابل كان عنا واقف بوضع غريب جدا اللي
هو لا هو ضغط على مسكر عليه زاويه تمرير
ولا انه مسكر الهاتف سبيس وبالتالي استلم
الكره باريحيه اعطاها لبرناردو سيلفا بنصف
المساحه
وتسجل هدف دور ستونز مواقف هون مبارح
نهائيا كان اللاعب اللي رودري عم يعطيه
المساحه لينطلق يعني مبارح الكل استغرب
انه نحن عم نحضر مباراه انه ليش ستونز عم
بيهاجم من اكثر لاعبين وسط اللي شفت معه
الكره هو جونس لانه هو اللي كان يبدا
الهجمه رودري كان يسحب مودريتش اللي كان
يحاول يغطي على لاعبي الوسط او السيتي
يسحب مودريتش يفتح المساحه على
يروح بفدانات المساحه ويفتح الملعب
بالنسبه للسيتي لذلك دور ستونز مبارح كان
جدا جدا جدا مهم وبالحديث عن ستونز لازم
نحكي ايضا عن لعب اخر اللي هوكر
اللاعب الوحيد هذا الموسم اللي فينا نقول
انه قدر يتفوق على فينيسيوس جونيور بنسبه
كبيره ان كان بمباراه الذهاب او بمباراه
الاياب مبارح ووكر كان غير طبيعي بلقطه
فينيسيوس بالدقيقه تقريبا 23 لو اي مدافع
اخر هاي الكره بالمرمى كانت اندفاع
انطلاقا من
فينيسيوس بالمساحه وكر وراه بخطوات بلحقه
بيعمل 180 درجه بيستدير بجسمه بيقطع منه
الكره بنظافه وبدون اي تدخل عنيف بيقطع من
الكره وبعيد الكره للسيتي وباكثر من لقطه
ووكر كان قادر انه يحد بشكل تام من خطوره
فينيسيوس جونيور وكان في صراحه مقوله حلوه
جدا بالنسبه للي عملوا امبارح اللي هو انه
اذا انت قدرت انك تسكر على فينيسيوس
جونيور بريال مدريد ريال مدريد ما عنده اي
مركز خطوره ثاني او مكان خطوره ثاني الا
فينيسيوس جونيور بالهجوم لذلك لما ووكر
امبارح نجح ان يغطي على فينيسيوس
ريال مدريد بيعرفوا انه الموسم الماضي
ريال مدريد اخذ البطوله يسميها ماشات
بالتوفيق بالحظ بالتحضير النفسي بالتحضير
البدني ولكن بكل شيء الا انه يكون عنده
منظومه الا انه يكون عنده فكره تكتيكيه
الا انه يكون عنده فريق قادر يشيله لسنوات
طويله ضمن سيستم كروي معين
بهذا الموسم ريال مدريد انكشف فعليا
انكشفت العيوب اللي موجوده عند انشيلوتي
انكشفت العيوب الموجوده عند كثير من لاعبي
ريال مدريد لانه ببساطه ما كان في التوفيق
اللي كان موجود بالمواسم الماضي ببساطه
واجه فريق عنده شخصيه عنده قوه ايضا وغير
قابل للايقافل وهو مانشستر سيتي ريال
مدريد اليوم بحاجه اعاده هيكله عامه يعني
اذا بدنا نحكي بكل صراحه عن الريال الريال
نص الملعب انتهى تقريبا عم نحكي عن كروس
مودريتش اعتقد انه انتهوا تماما اظهرت
ريال مدريد ايضا نفس العمليه امبارح كان
غريب جدا كل الناس متوقعه انه ينزل بالابا
كلفتا لاعب نص ملعب تفاجانا قاعد بيلعب
ظهير يسار والمشكله انه ما فيك تلوم
انشروتي على تلعيبه كمافينجا ظهير يسار
لانه ما عنده بديل نفس الشيء بالنسبه
لكربخال اللي مبارح يعني جريل فيه العمايل
مع المسانده اللي كان يعطيها دي بروين
مثلا مثل ما شفنا بالجول الثاني دي بروين
رايح عامل كثافه على اليمنى بالنسبه لريال
مدريد اليسرى للسيتي سحب معه توني كروس
فتح الهافاس
انطلق من المساحه سددها كورتوا ولما
جندوجن هجم بالمساحه كان عليه اربعه
لاعبين من ريال مدريد اربعه لاعبين كانوا
مغطين على وبالتالي كانت برناردو وهلانت
فاضيين بشكل تاب وهذا الامر اللي تسبب
بالهدف الثاني لريال مدريد فعم نحكي عن
انه كارفاخال ايضا نفس المشكله
قادر انه يرجع ويقدم مستويات الكبيره
بالمستقبل ريال مدريد محتاج للكثير من
التعاقدات حتى بتزيما اعتقد انه انتهى من
بعض الكره الذهبيه ما عاد في شيء اسمه
بنزيما اللي كان الموسم الماضي رودريجو
نفس العمليه لذلك اعتقد انه انشيلوتي راح
يكمل الموسم المقبل على ما يبدو ولكن
الافضل لريال مدريد انه يبلش مع مدرب شاب
يبني منظومه جديده لانه هذا الجيل بالنسبه
للريال برايي الشخصي انتهى بشكل تام اذا
مبروك لعشاق السيتي لعش اق ريال مدريد
والسيتي والانتر على نهائي دوري ابطال
اوروبا خبرونا شو توقعاتكم مين راح يتفوق
بين الفريقين وحتى ذلك الحين الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]